ils sont une demi douzaine il se
prénomme thomas jérémy eagle arnaud ou
encore et james eux ce sont les membres
d'électro de luxe cinq albums à leur
actif depuis 2001 le dernier date de
2013 dans sa version deluxe justement
ils se produisent ce soir sur la scène
de la batterie à guyancourt et nous les
avons rencontrés pour kiev
bonjour les trop de luxe bonjour à
thomas à gaël et à jérémy donc trois des
membres de la formation vous allez
procéder à la balance dans quelques
minutes c'est une salle un petit peu
plus petit ici par rapport à ce que vous
avez pu me faire vous avez fait des gros
festivals il n'ya pas longtemps encore
vous la présenter comment le concert de
ce soir dans une salle comme ça plus
intimiste peut nous en fait on adore les
clubs on adore cette configuration de
salle de 500 places ont c'est vrai qu'on
a la chance de faire des beaux festivals
et puis on a eu la chance l'année
dernière de faire l'olympia
mais on continue à faire beaucoup de
clubs parce que on aime cette proximité
avec le public ça permet de tester des
choses c'est exactement ce soir on va
d'ailleurs carrément essayer des
nouveaux morceaux qu'on a répété hier
donc c'est tout neuf tout frais du
public ce soir nous servir de cobaye un
petit peu et on a voulu intégrer à notre
fête qui est déjà très huit autres héros
des deux nouveautés pour c'est la
meilleure façon pour
pour les jauger les morceaux pour savoir
quel retour on aura sur ce morceau pour
clarifier les choses pour ceux qui
connaissent pas votre univers influence
au jazz rap soul et puis malgré le nom
électro de mousse
parce que l'électronique il ya beaucoup
de musique des vrais instruments sur
scène décrit pour notamment couvrir un
petit peu à contre-courant aussi de ce
qui se fait pourquoi c'est devenu à
contre-courant c'est à dire c'est que
nous on a l'habitude de dire être de lui
que c'était un groupe de musique quoi ça
avec des instruments d une basse une
batterie des cuivres et on a constaté
qu'on est en devenait marginal dans les
festivals notamment qu'on fait où il ya
beaucoup de projets électro qui ceux qui
sont en concert mais voilà nous c'est
devenu notre originalité
le nom le nom logan le terme ça
oh mais ça
chiche
ah ah
une autre de luxe qui est dans sa
deuxième vie en fait parce qu'il me
l'arrivée du chanteur 2010 chanteur qui
n'est pas là encore mais qui sera bien
sûr scène salaires qui vont arriver
qui sera là avec vous la rencontre juste
pour revenir sur ça pour expliquer cette
sa naissance de la deuxième vie du
groupe electro deluxe
c'est quoi un hasard 2010 c'est un très
très grand hasard c'est à dire qu'elle
est trop de luxe jusqu'à la rencontre
avec james copley fonctionner comme
beaucoup de groupes avec ce qu'on
appelle des featurings des invités sur
les disques on a pu leur invité rappeurs
chanteurs chanteuses et sur scène on
allons prenez ce qui était disponible
on avait vraiment envie d'une figure de
proue pour notre musique qu'un qui
l'incarné qu'il la défende tous les
jours qui intègre le groupe ne s'était
pas qu'au hasard y avait une volonté ou
d'avoir aidé un chanteur mais ont galéré
à trouver vraiment on avait beaucoup de
mal à trouver et puis un jour on entendu
parler d'un chanteur qui avait fait des
siennes dans un karaoké de séminaires et
une copine radio et j'ai vu un chanteur
chante est incroyable je crois que le
graet américain je les filme et m'a
montré la vidéo et on a trouvé ça
incroyable et on l'a appelée est venu
tout de suite il était du coup pas du
tout chanteur qui bossait pour une
marque de fringues et on a halluciné des
lois mais moi je pressentais en lui-même
et ne change rien c'est parfait s'en
sort plutôt bien
oui son sort il a vraiment ça dans le
sang il est d'une famille de chanteurs
mais lui même avait choisi une toute
autre voie
chacun a amené à mener sont sa couleur
et sa sa couleur à lui là il a ramené
avec tout ça
toute sa culture sont tous sont baghran
deux fils de pasteur thomas wipf en
avant tout jean est ce que c'est
c'est un comédien avant tout ça veut
dire qu'on ne peut pas rester assis un
concert d'électro c'est impossible c'est
impossible on peut pas il fait il est y
communique sa son énergie à tout le
monde
il voit la somme
il avoue
ayez un
du lot
d
l'alcool mais le la scène et c'est deux
choses différentes et souvent on
commence par l'album dans l'ordre et on
se dit qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
mieux
après on reprend
l'album on leur travail on le retourne
en fonction de la réaction des gens et
puis avec l'expérience des concerts on
arrive à ficeler un spectacle quoi
dernier album c'était 2013 une version
deluxe justement de l'homme
vous travaillez sur le prochain
justement en testant des morceaux ce
soir un petit peu ou alors on est en
pleine phase de composition d'écriture
de répétition décès comme on a dit on va
jouer des morceaux ce soir on a on a un
album en préparation qui sortira l'année
prochaine
m les morceaux avec cite aussi notamment
les morceaux des mythes assaillantes
aussi console la prochaine collaboration
ce sera quoi ça on peut pas le dire
c'est secret mais on a toujours des
envies
dernière question plutôt le swing de
duke ellington be bop de charlie parker
ou le cow boy and rules d ici on peut
faire un groupe avec les trois ça serait
bien annuler 150
moi je dirais le cool jazz de miles
davis à comprendre très bien merci
beaucoup mais trop de l'x merci mon
concert pour ce soir et dans une
continuation aussi puisqu'il ya d'autres
dates elles sont retrouvés sur le site
internet du groupe
un simple merci